i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle thanks for being with us tonight
china's bffs that's the focus of
tonight's angle
[Music]
the biggest reasons for democracy's
weakening
is the profound change that's taken
place in how we communicate and consume
information our new information
ecosystem is turbocharging some of
humanity's worst impulses lies
conspiracy theories junk science
quackery
white supremacists
racist tracks misogynists screeds
people are dying
because of misinformation
okay this is rich with his party on the
brink and his former vp on the ropes
barack obama thinks that he's going to
what turn the tide by attacking the few
news sources in the united states that
are actually telling the truth
about the results of his party's
policies
so labeling the views of an effective
opposition as dangerous disinformation
which is what he did today at stanford
it's the common tactic of dictators like
putin and she
so this brings me to this question why
is the left why are democrats so cowed
by china and so condemnatory of their
own country
now we all know that the left doesn't
think twice about punishing perceived
wrongdoers here at home
when the lgblm cdc announced new rules
you better follow them or else
you use the wrong pronoun
you're banned
post that you didn't get your booster
shot
hey you could lose half your following
on twitter
you raise your voice at a school board
meeting oh
the doj is going to put you on a terror
watch list or threaten to
but where are the left social order
enforcers when it comes to china
even when the ccp is starving 25 million
people in shanghai
even when they're crushing freedom in
hong kong or funding russia's assault on
ukraine spreading anti-american bile
online
covering up the truth about covid
imprisoning the uyghurs bankrolling
russia's war in ukraine
biden's team continues to pretend that
president xi is someone we can work with
in good faith
take climate czar john kerry who's kind
of like a desperate girlfriend begging
her ex to get back together long after
he's moved on
some of the differences of opinion
between our countries have been hardened
and sharpened
and that makes the diplomacy more
complicated uh i am in touch with my
counterpart to shia jemwa he's working
in good faith but if climate becomes one
of the tools one of the weapons
in the bilateral
back and forth uh we're cooked we're in
serious trouble
oh yeah we're cooked all right because
china is playing you every step of the
way john
mouthing platitudes about the climate as
china moves forward full steam ahead
building cold plants just as they always
were it's ridiculous
and china obviously knows it can just as
easily bamboozle our defense secretary
the chinese wouldn't even return lloyd
austin's multiple calls for what almost
a year and when they finally did take
his call this week it was only after the
ccp announced its new security pact with
the solomon islands which gravely
weakens our position in the region
austin got nothing from his talks except
an earful about how america needs to
stay out of the whole taiwan situation
this is just another biden diplomatic
failure
this is not what they promised us as joe
biden is probably the most experienced
foreign policy expert
since
george h.w bush
i support joe biden because beginning on
day one
he will restore americans leadership and
restore the alliances we need to address
the dangers that threaten our nation joe
biden will restore our battered standing
in the world
because he knows that our true strength
comes from setting an example that the
world wants to follow
the world wants to follow well of course
this was all smoke and mirrors
for the decades that i've been in
washington biden has always been known
as kind of a goofball grifter a
gladhander
china knows it owns biden and that he's
never going to stand up to them
biden showed his true colors remember
during a speech there in 2011. i
recognize that many of you in this
auditorium
see our advocacy of human rights
as at best
an intrusion
and at worst an assault on your
sovereignty
i want to tell you directly that this is
not our intention
and even biden said that he understood
china's one child policy of forced
abortions
but as i was talking with some of your
leaders you share a similar concern here
in china
you have no safety net
your policy has been one which i fully
understand i'm not second guessing
of one child per family
now imagine if he was this understanding
to conservative americans and their
concerns at home
but the truth is this soft pedal
approach to china it's not limited to
the democratic party and politicians
they're not the only powerful people
bending over backwards to accommodate
china
just think about how disney blew up
against governor ron desantis in florida
over that parental rights and education
law
we have to protect trans kids they said
but if disney really cared so much about
lgbtq rights
why are they silent about china's
increasingly hostile attitude toward
gays
or when china edits the gay scenes out
of american films and tv shows
or when they demand only masculine
characters on tv
well of course the same liberals are
fine though when twitter censors and
suppresses conservatives like trump and
even yours truly
and even as china has banned twitter in
their own country since 2009
the twitter mafia continues to give the
chinese government accounts free reign
they have free reign to trash america on
twitter 24 7. no repercussions in big
tech for china ever
the sell-out of freedom at the nba
though is just as bad
after supporting the radicals at blm and
railing against america for its
structural racism the nba is in a
perpetual bow to china
all to preserve its lucrative tv deal
there
so lebron and the biggest nba stars feel
so virtuous opining about how bad things
are in america for black people
yet they will not say a peep about the
horrific abuses happening to millions of
oppressed chinese
social justice frauds all of them
but this sucking up to china goes far
beyond the nba too
and it goes to most of the major media
outlets in the united states
where's the outrage about china's zero
covert policy
millions upon millions in shanghai are a
risk of starvation
thousands forcibly pulled out of their
homes separated even from their kids
and our press does everything in its
power to kind of sidestep what's really
happening there china the other big
country dealing with this they have a
different policy it's a zero covered
policy
uh they haven't quite achieved that
obviously but they are having some
progress beijing's zero covet policy
appears to be quite successful quite
successful
and not just that they're ignoring or
downplaying china's role in keeping
russia afloat financially during the
ukraine invasion
now meanwhile they brand anyone who
questions our own military involvement
in ukraine as pro-putin
of course none of this makes any sense
because you really can't be anti-putin
if you're also pro-g which our press
effectively is
so what does the left's refusal to stand
up to china tell us
i think it proves that they believe in
nothing except money and power
it's a left really cared about autocracy
and racism genocide islamophobia gay
rights potential climate
then they would criticize china more
than they criticized say
florida or texas
and this also proves that any democrat
who claims to care about china you
remember tim ryan in ohio is either
naive or just lying
having biden in the white house is
china's dream come true and anyone who
supports biden is just helping china
this also proves that the democrats were
never intending to pivot to asia
remember that
they're going to concede asia to china
and i guess just focus on defending
eastern europe against china's ally
russia
twisted but it's true
it also proves that democrats believe
conservative americans are a bigger
threat than the communist chinese
have you ever heard biden's attorney
general or kamala harris criticized
china like they criticized the rally
attendees on january 6th
it proves that democrats are either
under the thumb of the donor class well
of course they are
unlike republicans who are fighting big
business over the china issue the
democrats are taking the side of disney
apple the nba and other big donors
finally their refusal to speak plainly
about china's abuses proves that
democrats just cannot be trusted to
manage our foreign policy
i think standing up to china is the
single biggest challenge we face today
and it's likely the biggest one we're
going to face for decades and with biden
we have a president who's compromised
because of his son hunter's big china
payout
the democrats may never want to cancel
china for all that it has done to
undermine our country and freedom
everywhere
but i fully expect that the voters in
america will cancel them in november
and that's the angle